hi everyone Karen warden with Phil
encourage the radio show we're here in
studio after our interview with Andy red
wine and storm would the filmmaking duo
be behind Paradise recovered and the
film talks about religious abuse it's a
narrative regarding Esther Harris and
her experience with leaving a group and
we decided to touch a little bit more on
what draws people into these groups what
type of person would find themselves
drawn to joining an organization that
you refer to in the film and maybe you
can shed some light on that sure I mean
there's a call for everybody everybody
is vulnerable different points in their
lives and so there's really there really
is a group for everybody I think what
happens is there's kind of an initiation
process with a group somebody's
vulnerable and they're looking for
something and usually usually a cult
group will put out some kind of
marketing tool like a tract or a
television show or a magazine or
something or even the like street corner
kinds of things well they don't reach
out to somebody and that the Internet's
another way that people do that and so
they get they kind of get this person
interested maybe the person signs up for
some free free literature or whatever
well then they're in the mailing system
and then a technique that cults often
uses something called love bombing and
what they'll do is they will you'll have
people come to their house they'll do
drive-bys they'll have people call them
on the phone whatever information that
they've given the group will actually
use that information to then contact
that person which sounds like marketing
right I mean that's what you would do in
marketing although it's pretty pervasive
so you can imagine if somebody was
pretty vulnerable they would be pretty
open to that kind of thing um so they're
they're thinking about that there
they're they're getting all this
attention that's new and they're reading
this literature and these kind of subtle
things are hinted at well you know we
know the truth like we have we have this
understanding about this nobody else
understands this the way we do and tell
us about you tell me about you and then
the information is kind of gathered and
then the message is kind of structured
so that each individual then kind of you
it works for them in that way it works
the messages kind of tailored to who
they are so ahead why just going to say
and we all go through different life
changes I this is a this has been stuff
I've been learning about to because
that's exact question that I you know
had for Andy you know and we've talked
to a lot of experts at wellspring and
you know I got to interview a few of
those people which is a resource center
to help people who have been you know in
different kinds of abusive relationships
and cults and different groups but it
really you know you all go everybody
goes through these times in their life
where there's a big change in their life
or their down about something or you
know they're they're just you know like
a kid goes off to college and he wants
to make a difference and he wants to do
something important or somebody just
went through a divorce or you know just
all these different life changes that
happen where if they get if they get to
you at the right you know moment that
anybody is vulnerable you know to two
different ways of getting at you and a
lot of it is people who really want to
do something good they want to make a
difference they want to be part of
something that that is helping people
that mean something that matters and and
so they get sort of you know love bombed
into this is the thing this is what
you've been looking for and not all
cults are religious in nature either
there there are business calls their
therapy calls there are all kinds of
different groups that
that get people to do things that they
wouldn't normally do so if you see a
loved one and then join this group and
all sudden they have this real change in
their personality they've completely
changed something like a kind of
overnight without a whole lot of
forethought or they're being kind of
secretive or they're saying you're not
you don't really I don't really want to
talk with you about this one say well
I'm gonna think of two or three
instances where people have come up to
us at film festivals and said my
girlfriend like I was dating this girl
and all of a sudden she was gone and we
had no idea what happened to her I had
entries in this group and so it's this
kind of insidious people do it for
friendship people do it for love I'm do
it for money because they think maybe
they're going to make if it's a business
call to finger to make money for therapy
maybe they've been abused and then the
therapist kind of gets involved in that
so there are all kinds of different
groups that people can get involved in
and what and what I would I you know
just to add you to the question not
wanting to take over but the next
natural thing I think that people ask is
sort of like well you know I've been
passionate about things you know I've
been in two different groups what when
does it cross a line like how do you
know you're not just in some group that
is doing good you are making a
difference and then what makes it cross
the line into being a dangerous or a
cult group where where you know yeah I
think I think for you know the danger
kind of for me exists when you know
you're cutting people out of your life
you're no longer involved with your
family you're no longer involved with
your previous circle of friends because
like strong even our good friends and
like I know you're really passionate
about film and like if you told me that
you were joining this new group and they
were all about filmmaking and I said
that's fantastic I would be supportive
of you and that and then if you said but
you can't come with me because you don't
understand you don't understand the
truth of filmmaking like there's only
really one way to do it we all know that
I mean you guys are filmmakers and you
know that they're there more than one
way to skin a cat
incentive and everybody everybody every
director is different every every DP is
different right and so to say there's
only one way to do this would be crazy
and so just is there are different kinds
of people in the world there are
different kinds of religious practices
spiritual practices whatever I think
when it crosses the line is when to you
that you start noticing that the person
has a different language that they're
using where their doctrine becomes more
important than the people around them
we're trying to think of some of the
other things that that would be kind of
clue you in to like something going on
that's not just like being
enthusiastically involved in a group
that's doing good look right you know if
somebody's moving all of a sudden or
they're marrying somebody kind of all of
a sudden because they're in this group
or you know a lot of people or they're
making some you know they're signing
some contract with some some group to
you know fulfill some destiny I it's
just it's kind of crazy if it's all they
talk about or fewer mark changes in
personality I you know if all of a
sudden they're acting out of character I
think I think those would be telltale
signs but there's something not quite
right and again we all do things and I
recently became you know vegetarian or
vegan or whatever and I mean there were
some changes in me I didn't lose my
family I didn't lose my friends I you
know I mean I gained some new friends
because of my interest but nothing to
nothing changed in that way in that way
so that's where it's kind of different
so what's the message you hope people
will take away from the film after
seeing it well
you want me to go first sure so um you
know I hope there's some things
specifically that we hope people are
become more aware of how these you know
how pervasive some of this abuse is and
for me more than that just that on a
level on a human level we aren't none of
us is that far apart from the person you
know that we see on the street or that
we meet in the health food store that
we're all you know we're all struggling
with the same things and that and that
we're all you know what's important to
all of us are our basic you know human
needs and that freedom is important and
that people shouldn't be you know
controlled and abused and and that we
should be working together to you know I
don't you know to help find people find
freedom that we should be honest with
each other that we should I hope it will
start conversations about these things
about faith about truth about religion
and spiritual abuse so that different
people from different signs of you know
life can talk about these things and
come to a better understanding and you
know start to concentrate on the things
that really are bad and evil and dark
and that we could all be working
together to solve it instead of arguing
about things that don't really matter
yeah lots of groups will use like this
kind of fear and and a lot of cult
survivors I hope see this movie I hope
people that are in groups currently will
see this movie if they're if they're
permitted by your group to do so a lot
of them can't watch movies so for
information is controlled so they're not
obviously you know if they got too much
information then that the whole system
of the cult would break down so again I
hope that they get a chance to watch
this movie
kind of see the control that's there and
you know that there are there is a
leader that's exploiting exploiting this
for them and it's it's it's
heart-wrenching because you know these
are people that really want gosh they
really really want to do good in the
world or they wouldn't they wouldn't be
a lying themselves with these groups
they really want to do good things and
so because and then that gets exploited
by a group that really just kind of
wants them for the end game which is in
the north but leader who's barely
narcissistic gets to be elevated and
then you know they reap the benefits of
the power and the money and and all that
and usually the not-for-profit status as
well so they don't have to pay taxes and
that furthers the Empire's well man
comes out and we hope people we your own
are by enemy you know we we hope
that people be interred you know I think
you know in the end we made a film
that's enjoyable and entertaining and
you know compelling and I hope the
people you know enjoy it as a movie too
we were in a film festival somebody s
storm you know who do you want to see
this film storm is ur tight I want
everyone on earth